vocês sempre falaram para mim me
aterrorizaram assim nos comentários las
veias pega uma mulher bonita porque tu é
rico e tu é famoso Cara eu estou aqui
para dizer para você que é verdade
quando eu tô fora do Brasil eu chego
numa mulher eu digo lá a mulher responde
oi é duas Coca Zero com gelo e limão
para mim por favor obrigado tá isso fora
do Brasil sei lá inglês em espanhol Cadê
que eu sei falar inglês e espanhol para
poder responder para a pessoa que eu não
trabalho ali naquele estabelecimento aí
eu pego as coca e entregue para ela
porque ela tá ali né eu fiz se eu quiser
ficar com alguém na Bélgica eu tenho que
ficar igual o Chaves comprando churros
dele mesmo Olá tudo bem Que tal a gente
dar uns beijos ah claro mas primeiro
você tem que me cortejar A Nossa você é
tão bonita que se você fosse uma carroça
Eu chupava até o pau do jumento você é
divertido vamos fumar um ali perto
daquele caminhão cara vem